SPEAKER 1: One of the
common mitigation strategies
we can use during an incident
is to simply add capacity
to handle unexpected
traffic or load.
However, this only works if
there's capacity available.
Running out a resource quota
can make a minor incident
into a major one.
Today I'll show you how to
keep track of quota usage
in your projects with
Cloud monitoring.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud enforces
quotas on resource usage
for project owners,
setting a hard limit
on how much of a particular
Google Cloud resource
your project can use.
Let's start by
reviewing the basics.
There are two types of resource
usage that we limit with quota.
The first one is rate quota,
such as API requests per day.
This quota resets
after a specified time,
such as a minute or a day.
The second one is
allocation quota,
such as the number of servicer
counts created in your project.
This quota does
not reset over time
but must be explicitly
released, typically
by deleting the resource.
You can see quotas
in your project
by going to the Quotas screen
under the IAM & Admin menu.
From there, you can see all
the quotas in your project
and how much of
them you're using.
You can use this to
figure out if you're out
of a particular quota.
And that's great,
but how can you
be more proactive about this
and prevent quota limits
from getting in your
way, especially when you
need more capacity quickly?
Well the good news
is that you can
get this information
in cloud monitoring
and even set up
alerts against it.
Let's take a look.
You can use the
Consumer Quota resource
to see the available metrics.
There are two
quota usage metrics
for rate and allocation, there
is a metric for the quota
limit, and finally,
a metric showing you
how many times you've
actually hit that limit
called quota exceeded error.
Start by selecting the
Quota Limit metric,
then filter it through
just the Logging service
and the Write requests
per minute limit.
In my project, that
limit is set to 60,000.
That's a lot of logging.
Now let's set another metric
showing how much of that
limit we're actually using.
This time, use the Rate
quota usage metric,
and again, filter it
through the logging service.
In my case, I'm
nowhere near the limit.
This is good news.
Finally, you can configure
an alerting policy
which can notify you
if you actually hit
quota limits on your project.
Use the Consumer Quota resource
in the condition configuration,
and select Quota exceeded
error as the metric.
Now group it by service
and configure the alert
to fire if any time series
exceed the threshold.
Now you'll know if you hit any
quota limits in the project.
You should know that not all
services support quota metrics
at this point.
Refer to the documentation
link that we'll
add to the show notes
for details on that.
Monitoring quota
usage in your project
is a great way to proactively
make sure you always
have the capacity
you need if there's
an unexpected spike in traffic.
Thanks for watching and
come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]